are there any retrospective or
prospective
studies
that you know about on psychedelics and
ufos or psychedelics potentially
summoning certain beings via some
meditative technique
so i again i was talking to this this
group in la that are doing they're
serious scientists
that have um
a potentially wealthy benefactor to to
do just this i mean i'm not doing the
study with them they just called me to
get my perspective
on it um and so i hope that they
go ahead and and do it because
you know there's there's lots of people
willing to partake in those kinds of
studies
uh there's frankly no nih program that's
ever going to be funded in the near
future
for for doing this kind of stuff for all
the reasons we know
um so
you know the uh a wealthy and interested
benefactor
um
is really the next best thing
for that
do psychedelics have any role to play in
the caudate putamen connection
and by the way is this a red herring
because earlier you mentioned well just
because it's overgrown here it could
imply a lesser growth somewhere else
yeah that could be what's actually wrong
that could be
yeah i mean or it could limit i mean if
you're you know if you it's like a fuel
injector um
uh
you know if you if you limit the amount
of fuel going into one part of the brain
uh then doesn't matter how good the
upstream process is if there's a
filter it never makes it you know the
rest of the way
um
now
where and how the uh
let's say dmt or these other
psychedelics operate and what they do to
the to the brain i i haven't seen
anything yet on it um
the problem is that these are of course
almost all
you know uh scheduled drugs meaning they
have limitations on their uses
and i do know of there's a guy at
stanford and there's a guy i think at
johns hopkins again i was asking my um
my
psychiatry chair neighbor about this for
exactly the reasons you're asking you
know who's doing these studies right now
um
and uh the guy in la uh is actually a
very well-known doctor uh in this area
so he's associated with the program with
that program that they're trying to run
and
i think the brain morphometry tools that
we're building
will be useful to these individuals and
the data sets that we're producing will
be useful to these individuals
um and how dmt or you know psilocybin or
you know lsd uh
work into it i i don't know
um so but i'll be fascinated to see the
results
do you surmise that psychedelics are
acting as a removal of filters and
allowing in senses sorry and allowing in
sensory information yeah absolutely yeah
okay and then this seems to me to be a
component of one generating it from
within one's own mind and then there is
possibly the other element of one
allowing in information that wouldn't
allow and then they have to mingle in
the same manner right right yeah i mean
i've said this before that whatever
people think
electrosensory
uh extra sensory perception might be
um
whether it's real or not and
uh
it has to overlay
it eventually wherever the information
comes in
it has to overlay onto the normal or it
seems to be overlaying onto the normal
senses
right people see things or they hear
things or they feel something emote
emotionally
um or some mixture of the of the above
so
you know you you have an internal screen
in your head you can close your eyes and
you can see things
when you dream you see it in even more
stark clarity
so
whatever the so-called antenna might be
it is
it somehow
sits on top of
the sensory system that you already have
and
overlays the information into that if
we are purely materialistic beings now
you can start asking questions about
consciousness
maybe it has nothing to do with the
brain at all but wherever our
consciousness resides out there in
the 23rd dimension or whatever
um that all the information is going on
back there all the passage of
information is going on back there
and then
it's basically
moving it back down into the neurons
and so we might never find the antenna
because the antenna actually sits out
there
maybe the ant maybe consciousness
there's a great physicist i think i have
i should find his
stewart hammer off
no no it's a different he's a he's a
german physicist from the 1950s 60s or
so he came up with this physics of um
you know one of these grand theories of
of physics
and basically
uh he he's not well accepted by many
people but he's still followed by some
this notion that
that structures of physicality can be
created that he he basically said that
at a certain level of complexity of a
structure that's formed you can
instantiate
a um a self-perpetuating
object an entity that he said is
for all intents and purposes
consciousness or the soul
so that you know his
theory his hypothesis his premise was
basically that
evolution
and brain structure etc the purpose of
it was to basically create the flowering
of an object that he would call
consciousness that could then exist
independently of the object that created
it
it's sort of like was the that the the
body is a birth is a birth vessel for
the formation and he said at least i
mean there's lots of
you know uh spirituality uh you know
religions and things that talk about
this notion from a purely less a
spiritual standpoint he was trying to
give well he wasn't trying to
he was basically giving a physical
a physics definition of how it would
occur and he wasn't looking for it
he just as he was looking at the
equations said this is something that
falls out of it